Oh sis I wanna say I am so proud of you
that means the world to me girl I love
you I don't usually interview people but
they asked me to come present for you
tonight so I flew in from New York and
cut my trip off early because I love you
so much and I'm so proud of you and your
music everything you're just so iconic
and you're a legend and you're an
inspiration and how did it feel up there
just to perform right now thank you so
much
first of all you shouldn't have done
that not for me but thank you I feel
honored um it felt really cool because
I've been really sick and just like a
disgusting mess in my bed and I was like
will I make it through this performance
so the last two days I've been like a
kind of just a fever dream so I'm just
happy I may I hit those notes and yeah I
felt really cool I mean I love the
Internet I feel like my whole life is on
the Internet grew up with the Internet
yeah and it's just like cool to be in
front of a bunch of people whose videos
I watch you know I think this is so much
it's my first time at this award show
and I just love that they have it it's
amazing how like YouTube in the internet
like they now have like their own award
show and just watching all these videos
and seeing everyone it's just it's a lot
of fun just to be in this room and you
don't look sick or at all like how did
you just perform on stage looks like a
lot of ginger shots four hours in hair
and makeup
got this weave together yeah a bunch of
advil Matt like drug cocktail and now
we're here and you're alive also I'm
very excited to go in the studio
together I know I know we I have I feel
like I have a song finally here and it's
been way too long
and we got it for Kim do it soon and
can't say the f-word on the show you got
a freaking do it
I'm week we're gonna freakin do it and
I'm really excited boots the house down
like iconic
af definitely and that the most iconic
thing ever and I finally yeah if you
like I have the idea so I promised you
when we first met that we got a do phone
together and it's but it's got to be
good that's the thing it's got to be
great I don't think we would do is gonna
be amazing
doing a music video is like that is
looking my favorite things to send
people oh my god our scenes together is
like they're so cute I still love them
so much like I I've genuinely like had a
blast I hope I feel the same way I loved
it I was like this is so much fun as
soon as I heard the song I was this girl
we allowed to say an effort she's a
freaking star an effing star yeah no you
are and like to see you've come so far
like that was like your first like
single and then all of a sudden song
after song like girl like you don't stop
you're in the studio all the time yeah
I'm in there all the time I better don't
stop I feel like I've worked so much to
capture this point where people like
listen to my songs that I like I don't
ever want to stop now you know like that
would just feel like like I'm not
honoring how much I love my fans and
stuff like that I'm sure you can relate
because like you're just like the most
non-stop person I know who still look
amazing to who looks freaking amazing
yeah being the most non-stop person I
know and also one thing I have to say
like not a lot of people managed to do
as much as you do and be nice to people
and like you're seriously like such a
nice person like I feel constantly
inspired by how nice you are to
everybody you mean but but yeah I I
don't stop and I don't want to stop cuz
I love what I'm doing so much I love it
you're doing I'm watching you like on
all your Instagram stories and just
seeing you with the audience like they
love you and just like all of your
outfits the hair the makeup you're like
slang and actually I have a new word
and the new word it's like the new
that's hot it's living
I just trademarked it yes I own it it's
this new information new information so
basically living equals living your best
life which is killing it and slang in
one word
we're slippers hoose live around the
world living it ice lived ice live and I
will you have to come just livin Tanana
which is my new house you just renamed
it I don't think that Entertainment
Tonight has ever heard the F word so
many times hashtags living I stand
behind that boots slivers for life
[Music]